what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
if this is your first time here my name
is richard and this is the channel where
i help you break into data science
and grow your skills in the field so
around this time last year i did a video
called
10 r packages you should know in 2020
and i got a lot of comments on it saying
things like richard you left out my
all-time favorite package or how could
you forget about this package
and my overall response to that kind of
boils down to two things
number one i structured that video only
to include
10 distinct packages so necessarily when
you're only talking about 10 packages
you're gonna have to leave some
out and then naturally too i was
targeting that video to people who are
beginner to maybe
uh intermediate at r and so for
up and coming data scientists who are
just learning r for the first time
i want you to have the packages and the
tools that you need to do
the tasks that you're probably going to
have to do in your normal day-to-day
well that's where this video comes in so
in this video i'm going to cover 20 r
packages that you should know
and now for this one all 10 of those
initial packages
if you saw that video all those 10
packages are going to be included
because
it's one year later all 10 of those
packages are still great
but we're just going to drill down a
little bit further
so the same types of tasks that data
scientists do
like manipulating your data set and
getting into it
getting it into an appropriate format
visualization of data
dealing with weird data types and object
types and structures
creating reports and interactive
applications and models and machine
learning
all that stuff is fair game i'm going to
go go through all the packages that
you're going to need in order to be
successful at those various tasks
so before we get into this subscribe to
my channel if you haven't already
also take just half a second to smash
that like button
as well as the notification bell so
youtube notifies you whenever i upload a
video
and then if you'd like to support my
channel i will have links in the
description to
my patreon account my paypal address and
crypto wallet addresses
whatever method that you prefer there is
up to you
your support is highly appreciated then
also in the description i'm going to
have links to things like
the awesome book r for data science by
hadley wickham
that's my all-time favorite resource for
learning r
and then where appropriate for these
various packages
tutorials that i've done on them and now
without further ado let's get started
alright so the first package on this
list like many of them
is going to be part of the tidy verse
framework of packages
and that's deply r so honestly if you
could literally only
learn one single r package the plier is
probably where you want to start
this is your go-to for all of your basic
data manipulation needs
so things like using the mutate function
for creating new variables based on
existing variables
you can use the select function for
extracting
columns filter for extracting rows
you can use the arrange function for
ordering the different rows
then you've got summarize for creating
summaries
that could be either grouped by certain
variables or ungrouped
and that's just scratching the surface
you can use these join functions for
combining and joining your tables
honestly there's
a lot of even more obscure functions in
dply r
but for your go-to functions for your
data manipulation needs
they're generally going to be in deploy
are so i recommend getting familiar with
this cheat sheet
like several others the links will be in
the description to these as well
package number two on this list is
another go-to for data manipulation
purposes
and it's called data dot table now the
main premise behind this is it
introduces a new structure called
data tables and it has a whole different
syntax from the tidy verse of working
with
these types of data structures so
i have to be honest i'm not as big of a
fan
of the syntax for data table it's
i think designed to be a little bit more
syntactically similar to sql
now i don't like it as much as your as
your basic tidy verse syntax
but some people do and i guess it's more
of a personal preference thing
but where data table really shines is
with
big data so i've had it happen before
i'm working with data sets that have say
hundreds of thousands of rows
and i try to do a read csv from that and
it just doesn't work
it crashes uh it just causes problems
but then you use the f read function out
of
data table and then it just it just
works so
data table is going to be most
convenient as opposed to dply r
when you're working with really big data
sets
third package on this list is another
one from the tidy verse
and that's tidy r now where this package
is distinct from dplyr
is the key focus here is getting your
data into tidy format
and what and what a tidy data set means
is a data set that has three uh
conditions met
number one every column is a variable
number two
every row is an observation and number
three
every cell has a singular value
now your key functions here are going to
be pivot longer and pivot wider
pivot longer is going to help you go
from many columns to many rows
vice versa for pivot wider you also have
some helper functions for
separating or uniting columns and things
for dealing with implicit or explicit
missing data
but it all comes down to this concept of
tidy data
because once you have tidy data that's a
really helpful format for doing pretty
much anything
so that covers the data manipulation
packages hopefully
with using those different packages you
can get your data into a good format
so that you can go on and do more
exciting things such as
visualization now the fourth package on
this list
probably needs no introduction it's
probably the most famous package in the
whole
r ecosystem and that's gg plot 2.
so the gg here stands for grammar of
graphics
and what that is is it's essentially a
framework for
sort of simplifying any graph out there
down to a few basic components
number one you have data number two you
have a coordinate mapping system
and number three you have objects so for
instance here this is a scatter plot
where
uh displacement is on the x-axis highway
miles per
hour is on the y-axis that's your
coordinate mapping system
and then your objects are all these
various points those are the objects
that appear on a graph when you're
working with a scatter plot
if we go over and look at another
example i created a super
boring and straightforward and easy box
plot here from the iris data set
where again my x variable is species y
variable is uh sepal length and
i have this optional color scheme here
which i don't necessarily need
but it makes the graph look a little bit
fancier
and my objects here are these box plots
again you can essentially boil
any graph down to those basic components
and
that principle is really powerful and it
grants you a lot of flexibility
one of the most difficult things for
newcomers with
r and data visualization though is
actually making these things look nice
because sure while this graph up here
maybe it does tell a story
it's not necessarily the most
aesthetically pleasing
and that's where the fifth package on
this list gg
theme assist is going to come in so
once you've installed and loaded gg
theme assist
it works as an add-in to our studio so
how this is going to work is
let's highlight our code here
then i'm going to go to under add-ins up
here ggplot theme assistant
so this is going to help us customize
the theme
that is the overall appearance of this
plot
now you have a lot of options here for
example
uh this panel background that's what
gives us this like gray background with
the white lines going
uh up and down here it kind of kind of
looks like a prison cell
uh i'm not necessarily a big fan of that
maybe i want to
get rid of that um maybe i want to
maybe i don't want to get rid of it in
fact maybe i want to
uh just make it a little bit lighter i
can do that with like a great 97
but i'll just get rid of those lines in
the background that's an
option if we go over here to title and
label
i could do things like giving this a
basic title like
iris box plot i'm happy with the x-axis
and the y-axis labels because those are
just
based on the names of those variables
then for the plot title i'm going to do
things like
give it a bold face make it a little bit
bigger
and then i'm going to horizontally
adjust it so
iris box plot is in the center here
so i'm going to do that and then
afterwards i'm going to click done here
and look at that not only do i have a
much better looking plot here
but see the plot looks a lot better but
it wrote all the code for me so
for those of you who are lazy or you're
like me and to this day you've been
doing this for years but you still
forget all the syntax
this is really going to save you a ton
of time
but then if you thought that package was
making your life easy
what if i told you rather than just
using a ui like that to customize the
look and the feel and the theme of your
plot object
you can use a ui to create the entire
plot object
well that's where our sixth package on
this list esquise
is going to come in so just like gg
theme assist
it works as an add-in to our studio so
once you have the package
uh installed and loaded and you've
restarted our studio
come up here to ggplot2 builder
and now the first thing up here is you
have to select a data frame from the
environment
i'm going to select the mpg data set now
you can actually select or select
out variables i'm just going to keep all
of them
and there is a legend that you're going
to be shown here where
uh orange where discrete variables are
in orange
continuous variables are in blue but
come down here to
validate the imported data now i'm going
to move
this window up here so that you can see
everything that's going on
okay so you've got the variables
in the data set up here and we can drag
them
to these boxes down here so i'm going to
move
displacement to the x-axis and then
highway for highway miles per gallon to
the y-axis
notice this automatically created a
histogram
i'm going to come down here and bam it
figured out that since we're plotting
two variables
i probably want a scatter plot you can
change that
based on what actually works for your
specific data but
notice it's pretty smart here then class
i'm going to put in
color and bam i've
pretty much created a very similar type
of scatter plot to what you saw
uh earlier in the gg plot 2 vignette i
can come down
here to export and code in the corner
copy this code to my clipboard
i'm going to close this out actually
paste this in my rstudio window
and i have that ext that exact same
uh scatterplot object all created over
here
so this is an absolutely beautiful thing
now i strongly suggest
actually getting familiar with ggplot2
like don't
get reliant on a skis actually learn how
to create these things from scratch
because it is going to help you learn uh
how ggplot2 objects are put together and
give you a lot more natural working
intuition
necessarily some of that goes away when
you're using a ui just to create these
things
but once you have an intermediate to
advanced understanding of gg plot 2
eskies is really going to save you a ton
of time too i think
so alright you have all these wonderful
data visualization capabilities and
that's
that's all great but it may happen to
you
certainly it has happened to me that
people come to you and say
well these graphs are all static can you
create something that's more dynamic
and that's where the plotly api comes in
so plotly has implementations in python
as well as r
there's a little bit of a learning curve
to it because it's different from
working just with ggplot2
uh but you can sort of take your
visualizations to the next level
so this is just a gallery of plotly
examples
uh here's an example of what some of the
different code will look like
as you can see it is overall pretty
similar to ggplot2 code
because there is kind of a grammar of
graphics framework underlying it
but you can just do more with plotly
with
a visualization that's been created
using the plotly api
so for example here notice that i'm
hovering over these points here
and it's telling me the x and y
coordinates then i can also do things
like
let's suppose i want to zoom in in
instances where the sepal length is
greater than
six i don't care about smaller than that
i can do things like
let's just zoom into these data points
up here
notice i've zoomed into that aspect of
the graph
i care about that more i can just see
that in greater detail
that gives me as the end user a lot more
um i can just do a lot more with it
maybe i want to double click here
because then i want to go back
so it's just a different style of
creating graphs than what you can get
from ggplot2 alone
that i highly do recommend learning once
you're familiar with ggplot2 of course
alright so we've covered all the
packages for your data visualization
needs
now we're going to move on to packages
that are going to help you deal with
somewhat problematic data types and data
structures
and now i'm going to go through these a
little bit faster just because
honestly there's not quite as much to
say for them
but package number eight is going to be
per r
so first of all the package does have an
awesome name
but even beyond that what it's going to
help you to do
is a couple different things number one
it's going to help you apply
functions to multiple different elements
of some structure
so think of it as an alternative to
creating a for loop where you're doing
the same thing
many times or even as an alternative to
the built-in
apply family of functions so we have
this
map family of functions which
these functions can be used to help us
return a list
or a character vector or a double vector
so on and so forth
but the primary function of parar
is helping us work with lists so we can
do things like filter them
and reshape them summarize join them
lists are a very flexible data structure
in r but i understand for beginners
they can be a little bit
counterintuitive and certainly have a
learning curve to them
and per r is really going to help you
with that
moving on to package number nine that's
string r
this one is pretty self-explanatory it's
going to help you deal with strings
so again let's go over to the cheat
sheet here
this does a really good job of laying
out all the capabilities of this package
things like detecting matches subsetting
strings
managing the lengths of strings mutating
them
joining them everything that you can
pretty much
regular expressions pretty much
everything that you can imagine
i have a tutorial all about uh string r
that i'll have in the description
then package number 10 is lubridate
because
honestly date times uh they can be even
more problematic and painful
even than strangs those of you who
disagree with that statement i just made
have obviously never dealt with
uh daylight savings time date times and
r
it can get it can get just incredibly
painful
so things like getting and setting the
components
extracting the various components
of date times and then just doing math
with your date times with
these various objects you've got periods
durations and intervals so all these
different
classes and data types that are going to
help you uh just work
work with date times and specifically
the differences between various date
times
next we have another package that has an
awesome name
and that's four cats do you get the
feeling that hadley wickham
or anybody else who was involved in the
creation of the tidy verse that they
really like
cats that's okay with me i like cats too
but anyway so four cats is going to help
us deal with
factors now these can be a little bit
counterintuitive and challenging for
newcomers to r
because you have to get used to the fact
you've got levels
for factors and those are numeric but
then
built on top of those levels you have
labels
which are categorical and so you've got
things like
fct reorder for reordering the factor by
another variable
fct infrequent for reordering a factor
by the frequency of values
re-level for changing the order of a
factor by hand
lumping for collapsing the least or most
frequent values of a factor into some
other category
and even things that just help make uh
visualizations for factors so just
visualizing counts by different levels
of a factor
a variable just a whole lot easier
once again this is another package that
i have a whole tutorial on i'll have
linked in the description
that covers all of our packages for
dealing with cumbersome and problematic
data types and data structures
now we're going to move on to packages
that are going to help you create nice
aesthetically pleasing reports now
package number 12 for this list
is one of my favorites of all time and
that's our markdown
so for those of you who are familiar
with jupiter notebooks for instance
our markdown is a very similar concept
except i personally like it
significantly more than jupiter
even so what our markdown is going to
help you do is create a script
where you've got a header you have
your markdown syntax for creating your
commentary
you have your code there in fact you can
embed your code in line
uh or do things like just use the
markdown syntax for creating tables and
headers and and
things like that but you also have your
output inside of the same
file so you can knit this into
whatever type of format you want whether
that's
uh html pdf word documents
whatever you need for your particular
audience it's
super easy to use and it's just
wonderful
for just keeping everything that you
need
in one really clean well organized
location
package number 13 on this list is cable
extra
now to sort of set this one up you have
to understand that tables created using
base r
are not necessarily the most
aesthetically pleasing
now embedded into the r markdown package
is this package called knit our and the
key function out of that
is this cable pat function now
cable helps you clean these tables up a
little bit
make them look a little bit nicer but
cable extra just takes that to the next
level
so this is another one of these uh
packages that i have a whole tutorial
over
so i'm not going to go into this in too
great of detail
for this video but just through
scrolling through the vignette for cable
extra
you just get the feel for how flexible
you can be with
our tables and just making them just
fit the look and feel that you require
that's just
that's going to be a requirement if you
want nice looking reports and tables
that covers it for all of our report and
table requirements
now package number 14 is an incredibly
special one
because this one consistently challenges
the bounds of what i even know are
possible using
r and that's shiny shiny helps you build
interactive web applications it breaks
this down
such that you have a server and you have
a ui
that's two distinct components with a
server
you have essentially the back end
functionality
now with the ui you have various inputs
and then also the outputs from the
things that are going on in the server
in a way that the end user can play with
things
see things change and absorb results
so if we go up here to the shiny gallery
once again if you go through this you
will see all kinds of things that
you never even knew were possible using
r at all but
hey if you master shiny you are a very
very powerful programmer that's all i'm
gonna say
package number 15 here is going to help
you take your more bare bones basic
shiny apps to the next level
and that's shiny dashboard so shiny
dashboard is going to shine when you
have
a shiny app that you can sort of boil
down to three distinct parts
a header a sidebar and a body
and even from this most basic dashboard
that you see
here this is a little bit nicer looking
than your basic shiny app
because you have a lot of nicer looking
more professional colors going on here
but shiny dashboard is just going to
give you a lot more
options for controlling the look and the
feel
and even some other functionality for
behavior
of what your application's actually
going to look like
we're saving some of the most fun topics
for last
package number 16 is going to help you
with all of your machine learning needs
and that's carrot so i just got done
doing a four part tutorial series on
carrot
because there is so much functionality
out of this package
basically everything that you could need
to do in a machine learning pipeline
whether that's things like actually
creating the data partition
so that you have a training set and a
testing set
pre-processing your data creating uh
some kind of training control
actually doing the training summarizing
your results
all of that is embedded here inside of
carrot it's
one package that has all this different
stuff all within one single package that
yeah it has a learning curve but once
you learn it
it's extremely powerful now with this
list
with specifically with number 17 i'm
going to cheat a little bit here because
for the most part i've tried to isolate
this to
singular packages whereas this package
here
tidy models it's not really one
package so much as it's a bundle of
incredibly small packages
so with carrot you have one single
package that has
probably literally hundreds of different
functionalities
whereas with tidy models you've got all
these
really small packages which each serve
distinct purposes
so things like r sample that's different
resampling approaches
that's a package recipes that's your
transformations for
pre-processing that's a package parsnip
is a package for
model creation yardstick for measuring
your model performance
so it's two very different approaches
for machine learning
now where i think that this is going is
four years from now
i think tidy models is gonna have a lot
of development
uh at this time that i'm recording this
video anyway
a lot of these packages aren't
completely mature and there's things
changing with them all the time
carrot is more mature but i do think
over the long run
things are going to go the way of of
tidy models
i will say too with tidy models
syntactically
i think it's a little bit more user
friendly and has less of a learning
curve
than carrot does so keep that in mind as
well
package number 18 is going to be for all
of your deep learning needs
and that's an implementation of the
keras api
so in full disclosure i am not a deep
learning expert by any stretch of the
imagination
however what i'll say is as easy as it
is going to be
the keras package is going and r is
going to make that for you
so there's an example here on the
vignette for keras where it kind of
breaks down an example for you but you
can do things like just defining your
model
and then using the same a sort of tidy
framework
adding layers to it you've got
functionality built in for summarizing
compiling the model specifying things
like your loss function
uh your optimizer your metrics of
interest
fitting the model the plotting
functionality is built in there
evaluation all that all that wonderful
stuff
so keras is the foundation for this book
uh deep learning with r it's actually
co-authored between
uh a scientist over at google and the
founder of rstudio
so that's pretty interesting if you want
to expand on
uh your deep learning knowledge but as
far as the implementation is concerned
keras has everything you're gonna need
so for package 19
here's the thing i get tons of comments
on my videos
asking me all about time series modeling
and the best packages for time series
and i gotta be honest i do a lot of
survival analysis in my day to day
but i haven't actually personally done
any time series modeling in
close to four years now i love time
series models
actually it's one of my favorite types
of modeling exercises
i just haven't done any of it myself in
years and
this particular package kind of snuck up
on me
because when i was doing time series
modeling myself last
it was with the forecast package and now
that package was superseded in favor of
this fable package
so this is an awesome package it
it allows you to do all of your time
series modeling
inside of the tidy framework that so
many of these other packages
uh allow you to work in but it gives all
this wonderful functionality for things
like
arima that is auto regressive integrated
moving average models
uh exponential smoothing my personal
favorite is linear
models with time series errors you have
all those options
and then obviously creating these
wonderful graphs with your forecasts as
well
now last but certainly not least is the
reticulate
package now for this one it's pretty
self-explanatory and there's not
honestly a whole lot to say about this
one either
but it's all about using python from
within r
so the cheat sheet for this is awesome
and it does a good job breaking down all
the capabilities here but
whether you're using an r markdown or
just a basic r
script you can go back and forth between
python code
and r code and even creating an object
even using our code and then
using python to take that same object
and just do other things with it
and it provides a very convenient uh
sort of mapping system
going back and forth between r objects
and python objects
the way i like to say it is r and python
don't
need to be competitors with one another
the advantages of each of them can
complement one another
very nicely and reticulate will allow
you to do that
so there you have it that's 20 distinct
packages in
r each of them kind of serving a
different purpose
even though you can bundle a bunch of
them together into different categories
of tasks
that you're most likely to do in your
lifetime as a data scientist
and now i say this all the time in my
videos on r
packages but i'm just gonna say it again
here
if you get comfortable with all these
packages let alone master them
you really are going to become a really
strong data scientist
you're really going to go from somebody
that if you started as a beginner or
somebody with no experience
you can consider yourself intermediate
or once you even start mastering these
and the ins and outs of them
maybe even you can start treading into
the advanced territory
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it please consider
sharing it smash the like button if you
disliked it
hey you can dislike this video too you
can even dislike this video twice
really tell youtube you disliked the
video either way leave me a comment down
below
tell me what your favorite r packages
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future
until then richard on data